monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices c'est vrai
monsieur le président que je retrouve
cette maison avec plaisir et plus encore
la commission des finances et je
retrouve des visages que que j'ai connus
comme collègues lorsque je siégeais au
sénat mais ils sont infiniment plus
jeune que moi naturellement ils sont
toujours là je vais je vais vous
demander simplement de remettre le
masque si c'est possible surprise en
excusant mais c'est la règle quand c'est
tous fixés nous très bien il faut des
règles comme en matière de finances
publiques
vous avez rappelé que vous avez rappelé
les objectifs assignés à cette
commission que j'ai l'honneur de
présider installé par le premier
ministre le 4 décembre
et donc nous avons dû le vrai en trois
mois nous avons procédé à plus de 100
auditions et établit un rapport
les 10 membres sont restés du début
jusqu'à la fin
très assidue dans les auditions et les
conclusions sont assumés par les dix
membres dans la diversité des
convictions des parcours des expériences
nous avons bien sûr pris acte de ce que
l'état providence avait été à la hauteur
des enjeux de cette crise et qu'il avait
engagé les moyens pour assurer la
protection des français et prévenir le
collapsus économique et social mais ce
faisant trois questions se sont posées
d'où vient cet argent jusque là
la bourse était serré et soudainement et
des milliards ont été injectés dans
l'économie est mis au secours de l'offre
de soins il faut pas s'y méprendre
ça n'est pas de l'argent magique on
s'est posé la question comment l'état
peut-il s'endetter dans un tel contexte
en fait l'état n'a pas eu de difficulté
à s'endetter
parce que l'épargné mondiale est
surabondante koné taux d'intérêt sont
extrêmement faibles et qu'au surplus les
banques centrales ont engagé des
programmes massifs de rachat des dettes
publiques
eh bien on s'est interrogé sur la
soutenabilité de la dette française
on évoque la dette qu'ovide
correspondant aux dépenses
spécifiquement liée à la crise mais on
peut dire que la france par rapport à
ses partenaires européens de la zone
euro à aborder cette crise dans des
conditions moins favorables parce que
depuis 1974 nous n'avons jamais
équilibrer nos finances publiques et que
depuis 1974 la dette publique ne cesse
de progresser 20 % du pib en 81 40 % en
90 60 % en 2000 80 % pour 2010 et 100 %
à la veille de la dette coheed des
crises que vide donc
la soutenabilité peut être mise en cause
à un moment donné la france va le sortir
de cette crise avec une dette publique
d'au moins 120 % du pib alors que
l'allemagne sera à 70 %
cette situation comporte au moins trois
risques que le premier c'est la hausse
des taux bien sûr les taux sont
extrêmement faibles aujourd'hui
consensus établi par les économistes
laisse à penser que ceci devrait se
prolonger des ans - joe biden a engagé
des programmes très volontariste aux
états unis 1900 milliards de dollars et
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences sur
l'inflation aux états unis et à un
moment donné la réserve fédérale peut
être amené à remonter les taux et un
effet de contagion peut s'opérer
le deuxième risque c'est la stabilité de
la zone euro car nous ne sommes pas
seuls dans la zone euro et il faut
prévoir que des règles s'appliqueront
demain et qu'il y ait un minimum de
convergence entre les principaux pays la
zone euro
faute de quoi il pourrait y avoir des
turbulences au sein de cette zone euro
je suis rappelé les taux d'endettement
respectives de l'allemagne et la france
ceci peut être un facteur de friction et
puis enfin nous sommes entrés dans un
monde où la crise peut devenir la norme
et si l'on devait affronter une nouvelle
crise où seraient les nouvelles
ressources
par ailleurs nous devons nous préparer à
assumer des programmes de transition
écologique sont parlé du financement de
la dépendance et d'un cinquième risque
s'il doit d'être instituées
nous avons constaté que si nos finances
publiques allez au fil de l'eau comme
elles ont fonctionné jusqu'à maintenant
c'est à dire une progression en volume
des dépenses de 1 % par an entre 2010 et
2020 et bien
pour stabiliser la dette il faudrait
attendre peut-être 2030 à des niveaux
supérieurs à 130% du pib et peut-être
même dans des conditions de croissance
moins favorable bien au delà si
heureusement tous les facteurs positifs
étaient réunies si les planètes
s'alignent et on peut néanmoins espérer
une stabilisation de la dette à hauteur
de 125 % du pib à échéance 2030
ceci pour souligner la nécessité d'agir
alors agir comment une première erreur
serait de restreindre les injections de
crédit tant que la crise n'est pas
terminée
les dépenses exceptionnelles doivent
être engagées il faut pas commettre les
mêmes erreurs que celles commises au
lendemain de la crise de 2008 et des
crises ouvre des crises des dettes
souveraines en europe dans les années
2010 donc maintenir cet effort mais bien
distinguer les dépenses exceptionnelles
qui disparaîtront au lendemain de la
crise de celle qui pourrait avoir un
caractère structurel et qui affecterait
le niveau de dépenses publiques
au delà de la sortie de la crise nous
préconisons également d'écarter les
fausses pistes qui sont dans le débat
l'une d'entre elles consiste à annuler
une partie de la dette
ceci n'aurait aucun intérêt compte tenu
du fait que la dette est largement prise
en charge par la banque centrale
européenne et par les banques centrales
étrangères à peu près 80% des titres
émis par la france en 2020 sont
aujourd'hui dans les livres de la banque
centrale ou des banques centrales
étrangères
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
titres émis correspondent à la fois
au déficit de 2020 c'est à dire un peu
plus de 180 180 milliards dirons nous et
puis le refinancement des dettes qui
venait à échéance en 2020 donc 80 % des
titres émis c'est plus que les 178
milliards et du déficit 2001 le défi le
déficit prévisionnel dans la loi de
finances que vous aviez voté plus les
dépenses spécifiques du fait de la crise
donc écarté les fausses pistes
si la banque centrale annulait une
partie des créances qu'il détient sur
les états de la zone euro ça n'aurait
aucune conséquence sur les comptes
publics puisque d'un côté même si les to
sont très faibles les intérêts payés
sont des revenus de la banque centrale
qui lui permet de payer des dividendes
aux banques centrales qui sont les les
sociétés mères de la banque centrale
européenne qui elle-même versent des
dividendes aux états membres
donc c'est un jeu à somme nulle qui n'a
aucun intérêt
mais ce serait un signal donné aux
marché et si un jour on a osé effacer
une partie de la dette les investisseurs
pourraient considérer que à l'autre jour
nous céderions à cette tentation et
c'est le crédit de la france qui depuis
plus de deux siècles à honorer ses
dettes qui serait mis en cause donc ce
serait une façon de scier la branche sur
laquelle on est assis
d'autres ont évoqué la dette perpétuelle
mais qu'ont donc la dette perpétuelle
c'est un créneau extrêmement étroit du
marché ah si vous connaissez des
investisseurs prêts à souscrire des
dettes perpétuelles ils récupèreront
jamais leur font et qui percevront un
intérêt somme toute très modiques donc
écarté ces fausses pistes alors la
question et vous le rappeliez faut-il
cantonner la dette qu'ovide moi j'ai un
souvenir du cantonnement je venais
d'être nommé à bercy en 95 et nous
constations que du fait des années de
crise de la récession de 93 il y avait
une dette de la sécurité sociale 250
milliards que faire de cette dette avec
le premier ministre alain juppé nous
sommes convenus de faire un fonds dédié
la caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale la cades s et puisqu'on n'avait
pas trouvé les moyens d'équilibrer les
comptes de la sécurité sociale jusque là
eh bien on était convenu de prévoir un
impôt spécifique que vous voyez
apparaître sur vous au bulletin de paie
la crds
ça devait durer quinze ans et au bout de
quinze ans c'était fini sauf que la
cades s est devenue la voiture balai des
déficits chroniques de la sécurité
sociale et qu'il ya une sorte de fuite
en avant tout cela pour dire que si on
fait un cantonnement il faut prévoir une
ressource affectée et donc un nouvel
impôt or compte tenu du tour des
prélèvements obligatoires en france nous
sommes sur la plus haute marche et donc
pas question prévoir un impôt
supplémentaire
je pense que il est bon de faire
apparaître clairement ce qu'est dans la
dette globale le montant de la dette
qu'ovide c'est un élément d'information
que l'on doit aux citoyens et aux
acteurs publics mais nous n'avons pas
recommandé de cantonnement en revanche
il pourrait y avoir comme le disait
avant-hier le ministre l'économie et des
finances un isolement de la dette que
vides c'est une présentation qui a des
vertus d'information et de pédagogie
alors quelles stratégies pour améliorer
la soutenabilité de nos finances
publiques nous avons écarté la voie de
l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires pour des raisons que je
viens de rappeler nous sommes
à 45 % dans la zone euro la moyenne
c'est 40% poursuivre dans cette voie
serait de notre point de vue contraire à
la croissance et à l'intérêt du pays
donc la seule voie possible c'est la
maîtrise de la dépense
nous devons veiller c'est la règle que
nous posons nous devons veiller à ce que
la progression des dépenses désormais
soit inférieure à la progression des
recettes
l'objectif étant le plus rapidement
possible d'aller vers la stabilisation
de cette dette pourcentage de dette par
rapport au pib
alors le jour où le pib va retrouver de
la consistance naturellement le le taux
va baisser ce qui explique qu'on soit
passé aussi rapidement
de 100 à 120 % est liée au fait que le
pib en 2020 a chuté d'un peu plus de 8%
donc ces dispositions mathématiques vont
oeuvrer dans l'autre sens mais nous
devons nous préparer à un reflux de la
dette publique en disant cela
faut pas perdre de vue quand même que
nous ne remboursons jamais la dette
j'ai dit plus de 40 ans de déficits
publics
et comment fait on est bien dès qu'une
dette vient à échéance
on la rembourse en empruntant
l'équivalent qu'est ce qu'on appelle
rouler la dette
donc on peut faire tous les
cantonnements qu'on veut mais en
pratique ça ne change strictement rien
et s'agissant du reflux de la dette je
constate que nous sommes relativement
désarmées jusqu'à maintenant on avait la
règle européenne
mais du fait de la crise la règle
européenne qui est basée sur deux textes
fondamentaux le le pacte de stabilité et
de croissance de 2010 est traité
d'amsterdam pas de déficit supérieur à
3% pas de dette publique supérieur à 60%
cet égard 3% j'ai l'impression qu'on
avait on en avait fait un objectif c'est
dire que quand on avait 3 % de déficit
c'était bien or en matière de pilotage
des finances publiques la règle c'est
quand même l'équilibré des finances
publiques
qu'on aille à 3 % lorsqu'on est en
situation conjoncturelle difficile
ça se comprend il faut soutenir
l'économie et permettent aux
amortisseurs sociaux de jouer le rôle
mais sur la durée ce donné comme
ambition 3% de déficit c'est accroître
méthodiquement le niveau de la dette
publique
ces règles là sont suspendues pendant la
durée de cette crise
mais ne nous méprenons pas il faudra
bien demain prévoir le retour de ces
règles sans doute différente parce que
revenir à 60 % d'endettement en 20 ans
comme le prévoit le six pack qui est le
deuxième texte
j'ai dit le pacte de stabilité et de
croissance mais il ya également le
traité stabilité coordination et
gouvernance le tsc g et de 2012 qui
était le renforcement du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance que la france
appliquait à l'époque un minima en
créant le haut conseil des finances
publiques
ces règles sans doute modifier vont
revenir
mais si nous voulons participer la
négociation des nouvelles règles encore
faut-il que nous ayons nous mêmes nos
propres règles et que la crédibilité de
ces règles elles soient compréhensibles
par nos partenaires pour qu'elle puisse
être une référence
alors osons sur le président se le
rapporteur général nous donner des
règles de gouvernance de nos finances
publiques nous avons une gouvernance qui
convenons-en inadaptée puisque on a
multiplié
les textes de progrès les lois de
programmation pluriannuelle qui n'ont
jamais été respectées
on est très vertueux quand on parle des
finances publiques mais on est très
dépensier lorsqu'on parle de politique
sectorielle et je me demande si parfois
la dépense publique n'est pas un
indicateur de performance
donc nous n'avons pas vraiment de règle
d'abord parce que trop souvent nous
agissons dans le court terme donc on
prend le rabot puis on passe à grand
coup de rabot ce qui n'a pas toujours
les conséquences attendues ça peut avoir
un affichage immédiat mais dans la durée
ça n'est pas véritablement efficaces et
nous avons des entités de dépenses
publiques qui sont terriblement éclaté
avec des réglementations spécifiques des
circuits financiers entre le budget de
l'état le budget de la sécurité sociale
c'est difficilement explicable et ceux
ci entretient une sorte de clair obscur
c'est peu dire que nos finances
publiques sont peu transparente
si vous arrivez à expliquer ce que sont
nos finances publiques à un citoyen un
document synthétique pourrait apparaître
par nature nos dépenses publiques et
puis nos recettes publiques
le niveau de déficit ou d'excédent et
puis le devenir de la dette
il ya là les salles sas et c'est ce qui
me donne beaucoup d'optimisme c'est que
nos marges de progression sont
considérables donc nous proposons une
transformation radicale de la
gouvernance budgétaire avec trois
piliers le premier pilier
c'est une norme de dépenses pluriannuels
avec un compteur avec des conteurs des
écarts nous voulons dire que lorsqu'une
nouvelle législature s'installe le
premier acte doit être la préparation
d'une loi pluriannuelle couvrant les
cinq années du quinquennat de la durée
de la législature et avant même que de
voter
la première loi de finances et la
première loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
on vote la loi pluriannuelle des
finances publiques dans laquelle on va
fixer une trajectoire veiller à ce que
la progression des recettes soit
supérieure à la progression des dépenses
et dans les dépenses
on s'oblige à fixer un plancher de
financement de ce qu'on appelle les
dépenses d'avenir les crédits d'avenir
nous avons longtemps délibéré pour
savoir s'il s'agissait exclusivement des
investissements et finalement nous
devons reconnaître qu'il y à des
investissements d'avenir comme il ya des
investissements qui sont pas forcément
des investissements d'avenir et qui sont
des activateurs de croissance et de la
même façon il y à des dépenses
récurrentes de fonctionnement qui
peuvent être des dépenses d'avenir
dépenses d'avenir étant la recherche
s'étend l'éducation se veut pas dire que
des crédits supplémentaires et soit la
seule réponse car ya aussi des problèmes
de gouvernance qu'il va bien falloir
régler par des réformes structurelles
formation professionnelle bien sûr
qu'ils sont également des
investissements d'avenir
donc premier pilier une norme
pluriannuel de dépenses votées par le
parlement alors à l'assemblée nationale
avec l'appui bien sûr du sénat et qui
n'a pas les mêmes les mêmes échéances
électorales donc là il faudra trouver
l'articulation
le deuxième pilier le premier pilier est
en quelque sorte notre boussole
budgétaire le deuxième pilier c'est la
vigie et la vigie pour nous c'est un une
institution à l'exemple de ce qui existe
dans de très nombreux pays de l' ocde
les modèles étant l'eau br britannique
l'office of budget responsability ou
bien
le cbo américain qui est rattachée au
parlement et qui est indépendant des
institutions de contrôle six jours de
contrôle tels que la cour des comptes
et cette vigie budgétaire et c'est une
novation doit presser doit elle même
fixé les données macroéconomiques
jusqu'à maintenant les données
macroéconomiques sont fixés par le
gouvernement sous le l'appréciation du
haut conseil des finances publiques dans
notre esprit c'est cette vigie qui
devrait présenter elle-même à l'opinion
publique
ces prévisions macro économique
croissance ton intérêt est de procéder à
des projections bien au delà de ce qui
est nôtre notre perspective la plus
longue
ici en france on a rarement au delà de
50 il n'y a qu'une guerre que le que le
centre de 2,2 déplore le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui
procèdent à des prévisions bien au delà
de cinq ans dans les autres bibelots cdo
ont fait des prévisions à 30 ans à 40
ans au canada on va soixante dix ans
c'est une façon de situer les finances
publiques par rapport à l'avenir et
cette vie j aurais pour pour mission
aussi de donner une appréciation sur
tout novation politique si le
gouvernement aussi le parlement vient
avec un projet important et doit être
procédé à une évaluation à son impact
sur les finances publiques et à sa
soutenabilité par rapport aux objectifs
à moyen et long terme nous pensons que
cette institution doit avoir des
collaborateurs at-on qu à temps plein ce
qui n'est pas le cas actuellement et
bénéficier d'une totale indépendance
collaborateurs qui peuvent être issus
des grands corps de l'état la cour des
comptes le trésor la banque centrale la
banque de france
la banque centrale européenne mais aussi
des économistes et ceux qui collaborent
le modèle britannique c'est une
trentaine de collaborateurs c'est un
budget
2 3 millions à peu près et puis
peut-être pourrait-on groupe et tous ces
conseils qui existe qui font tous de la
prévision
chacun dans son secteur sans qu'on ait
de vision véritablement globale et puis
le troisième pilier que nous proposons
c'est un débat parlementaire qui
permettent une appropriation par les
français les débats budgétaires
d'abord et là je réitère ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire dans ce que je
siégeais et dans cette assemblée et que
nous passons beaucoup trop de temps pour
l'examen la discussion des projets de
loi de finances
cela pourrait durer quelques jours comme
dans nombre de pays
en revanche nous ne poussons pas
suffisamment de temps et sur l'examen
des lois de règlement il faudrait
également restitué une loi de résultats
pour la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale est organisée au moins
annuellement à grands débats et sur les
finances publiques avec the lady une
présentation globale et cette
présentation globale pourrait être dans
l'article liminaire du projet de loi de
finances comme dans leur projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale
présentant la synthèse des recettes et
des dépenses publiques par nature et les
prévisions les trajectoires de la dette
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général en quelques mots le
résumé du rapport que j'ai eu l'honneur
de présenter au premier ministre la
semaine passée le 18 mars en compagnie
de mes neuf collègues collègues qui
étaient français mais nous avions
également deux économistes étrangers
européens
l'une qui a conseillé madame merkel et
monsieur schröder au conseil qui
existent au près la chancellerie
allemande
et puis un autre qui a été conseiller du
ministre des finances autrichien et qui
a également été
dans le noyau open fiscale groupe en
charge de la gouvernance de la zone euro
donc tous en vue n'ont pu avoir des
appréciations des appréciations pas
seulement française et ceci pour nous
était important donc peut-être devrait
souligner quand même l'importance de
l'europe parce que si on n'avait pas eu
l'europe
on peut se demander quelle était la
situation en france
dans la première crise de 2008 je pense
que nous avons résisté parce que l'euro
était un bouclier et s'agissant de la
crise du coc vide
demandez vous si l'état aurait été en
situation d'emprunter aussi massivement
à des taux aussi faible et si nous
n'avions pas été en relation directe
avec la banque centrale européenne
l europe a également manifesté sa
solidarité puisque le conseil le
parlement l'a ratifié le conseil a prévu
que ces circonstances exceptionnelles
justifiait un programme de 750 milliards
et à faire l'objet d'un emprunt donc la
solidarité européenne jouer la france va
bénéficier de 40 milliards de dotation
pour engager des dépenses
exceptionnelles
c'est le plan de relance mais le
préparons nous à en rendre compte à nos
partenaires lorsqu'il va s'agir de
rétablir des règles pour le
fonctionnement de la zone euro est la
zone euro à cette spécificité qu'elle
n'est pas européenne c'est une addition
de dettes souveraines nationale
contrairement contrairement à la dette
américaine qui est une dette fédérale et
donc les investisseurs peuvent à tout
moment jouer un pays contre l'autre et
faire subir ce qu'on appelle un spread
c'est à dire des écarts de taux
d'intérêt et consistant donc préparons
nous à retrouver ses règles parce que
sans cela la zone euro pourraient être
mises en danger
ces règles vont revenir sur la table
sans doute au lendemain des élections
allemandes de septembre prochain il
faudra redéfinir
ce que peut-être le pacte de stabilité
et de croissance il faudra également
revoir le dscg le tout pas que le six
pack
donc nous serons d'autant plus crédible
dans ces négociations et le poids
politique de la france sera d'autant
plus fort pour faire prévaloir son point
de vue et que s'agissant de la stratégie
de gouvernance budgétaire nous aurons
fait des propositions marquée du signe
de la responsabilité de la lucidité
voilà monsieur le président donc
peut-être qu'au moment le premier
ministre nous confier cette mission
début décembre il avait le sentiment que
fin février mi mars nous serions sortis
de la crise qu'ovide n'y sommes pas et
donc ce rapport est naturellement
chargée de beaucoup d'incertitudes comme
le sont les propos que je viens de tenir
devant vous merci et merci monsieur le
président merci d'avoir résumer en une
vingtaine de minutes je veux dire un
rapport très dense vous dire que
je pense que la quasi totalité de nos
collègues ont lu ce rapport et anne ont
tiré tout le même temps des questions
nombreuses à vous poser je vous signale
que nous sommes déjà douze inscrits 13
ça va donc traditionnellement je vais
demander alors c'est compliqué sur un
sujet de cette nature qui qui par nature
ouvre des horizons très large
à chacun de se maintenir entre 2 et 3
minutes
j'ouvre un peu j'ouvre un peu la porte
parce que le sujet mérite
je vais vous proposer monsieur le
président d'entendre l'ensemble des
interventions et de bien vouloir faire
un exercice de synthèse puisque il y
aura sans doute des rebonds sujet par
sujet si je puis dire
et voyez-vous quand j'ai préparé cette
audition je me suis dit est-ce que je
vais poser des questions alors j'ai
arrêté parce que j'en avais une dizaine
et donc j'ai dit si je me lance dans dix
questions je vais avoir des regards
noirs autour de moi dont j'ai proposé de
ne pas vous poser de questions tant que
président peut-être à la fin si jamais
il y avait un thème qui n'était pas
abordé mais ça m'étonnerait qu'ils ne le
soient pas tous jeux java porterait un
de plus je vais donner la parole tout de
suite aux apporteurs général merci
messieurs les présidents
mes chers collègues en moi j'aurai deux
fois moins de questions que celle que
vous aviez prévu
monsieur le président ce qui va vous
rassurer et je vais effectivement essayé
d'être court d'abord jeu comme le
présent claude raynal eux non seulement
vous vous saluer pour ce retour dans des
travaux d'une commission vous avez
fréquenté mais pour le le travail qui a
été produit
j'ai bien entendu de avec des experts
des personnalités de sensibilités
politiques différentes et même de pays
différents
c'est un regard qui est intéressant je
vais rentrer à la fois dans le vif du
sujet à travers cinq questions sur des
sujets parfois de méthode et parfois de
contenu et je vais essayer donc pour que
chacun ait le temps de me tenir autant d
en gros trois minutes d'abord je vous
dire que finalement j'éprouve une
certaine satisfaction à voir que
certains des axes de la stratégie
budgétaire que vous proposez reprennent
assez largement les orientations que
j'avais moi même formulé lors de
l'examen du budget à l'instar par
exemple de redressement des comptes
publics à compter de 1023 une fois le
pibe revenu à son niveau
souhaitons le d'avant crise où
l'invitation à privilégier la maîtrise
de la dépense 100 et vous l'avez dit
sans hausse d'impôts mais j'ai à ce
stade à un regret c'est que la
commission ne se prononce pas sur un
objectif de dette ou de déficit à moyen
terme et en l'espèce se contente je
dirais d'établir des scénarios ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas toujours aisé à
appréhender en fait
j'attendais finalement un peu un point
de vue ne peut être une provocation de
votre commission sur ce terrain est ma
première question c'est est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut finalement se
contenter de stabiliser d'endettement ou
est de le réduire
et si oui à quel rythme vous l'avez
évoqué mais sur le rythme voilà c'est à
la fois du vous expliquer du plus tôt au
long terme
voilà c'est cdc ça pourrait nous
éclairer sur j'ai une question un peu de
méthode et de règles que votre
commission propose d'adopter au niveau
organique
une nouvelle règle en dépenses alors
même que nous avons déjà plusieurs et
que le pacte de stabilité européen est
en cours de renégociation et ma question
c'est en quoi cette règle selon vous
apporterait tel finalement un plus par
rapport à la règle en dépenses
européennes existantes ou les objectifs
des forces structurelles fixé par
exemple dans la programmation est ce
qu'il faut vraiment révisé dès
aujourd'hui la loi organique sur ce
point alors même que la règle que vous
proposez risque d'entrer finalement en
compétition peut être en contradiction
et ou de se superposer aux futures
règles budgétaires européennes
c'est un peu kafkaïen j'en conviens je
partage comme je les dis la nécessité de
maîtrise de la dépense publique voire de
réductions lorsque la crise sera passée
et je partage vos intentions violentes a
proposé de définir des dépenses d'avenir
qui seraient et je le partage également
préservé des efforts de redressement à
venir je pense toutefois que la solution
proposée à savoir de fixer un niveau de
plancher d'avenir n'est pertes et moi de
le dire pas assez ambitieuse parce que
il faudra par exemple est fortement
relevé le verdissement de nos
investissements
lors du prochain quinquennat si l'on
veut et je crois que nous le devons
respecter nos objectifs climatiques
la vérité c'est qu'en fait il faudra en
même temps augmenter les dépenses utiles
à la croissance et réduire les dépenses
courantes
la question ses articulations vertueuse
ou porte à faux j'ai besoin d'avoir
monsieur le président votre avis sur le
sujet et enfin déterminer les dépenses
dites d'avenir sera cruciale puisque le
rapport
et je peux le comprendre mais pas très
précis sur ces dépenses d'avenir qui
pourraient être concernés de même qu'ils
ne donnent pas vraiment dax de maîtrise
de la dépense publique donc ce qui est
ce qui serait intéressant c'est de vous
entendre sur l'endroit les endroits où
les efforts devraient être portées en
priorité ce qui entraîne des arbitrages
mais ce qui est aussi le travail de nos
assemblées de débattre et de définir
quelle pourrait être qu'elle devrait
être
ces arbitrages deux dernières questions
courtes une première vous propose et je
suis toujours un peu inquiet de
d'élargir le nombre des collectivités
locales concernées par les contrats de
cahors je rappelle qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui
322 qu'elles représentent près de 70% un
tout petit peu moins la dépense locale
de fonctionnement au passage ça ils ont
démontré qu'elle savait très bien se
tenir beaucoup mieux que l'état et donc
la question c'est quelle serait pour
vous la part d'aidé de ses dépenses qui
devraient être concernés par le
dispositif que vous préconisez des
larges et ce qui n'est pas d'ailleurs
sans poser des questions également sur
finalement l'autonomie des collectivités
locales je ne qualifie pas l'autonomie
dans un dans une république française
dont il est dit dans la constitution
qu'elle est décentralisée enfin vous
proposer de consacrer un temps plus long
à la programmation pluriannuelle en
début de mandature et pour cinq ans je
ferai une première remarque il suffirait
d'appliquer en test sur le quinquennat
en cours
votre méthode je pense que assez vite
elle pourrait être prise en défaut
si on regarde la période 2010 est au
jour où je vous parle
mais bon alors peut-être que il faudrait
effectivement adopté la programmation
avant le premier budget mais dans ce cas
là comment concilier ce souhait avec le
calendrier budgétaire vous le savez très
bien
l'assemblée nationale à 40 jours nous
avons un jour on a mangé pas le
sentiment qu'on en bim
alors on peut améliorer quelques
éléments certainement peut-être dans la
procédure mais il faut faire attention à
ne pas en prime est cadenassé les débats
et le les procédures à moi
et là je ne souscris pas de réduire le
temps consacré à l'examen du budget
parce que je rappelle que s'agissant du
contrôle budgétaire
le sénat le fais au long de l'année de
manière bien différente et je dirais
selon moi plus approfondie que la
deuxième chambre
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
je vous propose pour suivre tout de
suite les informations des collègues en
vous signalant simplement que maintenant
le cahier est fermée puisque nous sommes
à 18 inscrits et que le temps s'est
raccourci à deux minutes deux minutes
deux minutes trente
il ya une tolérance merci donc nous
démarrons avec vincent delahaye merci
monsieur le président merci cher jean
arthuis je me suis dit au début quand
j'ai vu que c'était jean arthuis qui
allait présider la commission des
recettes à venir des finances publiques
je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il va faire
dans cette galère
et finalement il s'en est pas si mal
sorti que ça d'après moi avec quand même
quelques quelques questions
et quelques désaccords alors je vais
essayer de faire court et
j'ai compris qu'il fallait avoir des
règles et je suis convaincu qu'il faut
avoir des règles dans pas mal de
domaines et dans le domaine des finances
publiques bien entendu après la
problématique c'est de les appliquer et
surtout qu'elle soit contraignant parce
que les appliquer on s'aperçoit bien que
en fait personne ne les applique donc en
tout cas en france et pour que l'on
puisse les appliquer il faut qu'elle
soit contraignante alors le plafonnement
pluri annuel des dépenses
pourquoi pas mais de quelle façon on
pourrait les rendre contraignants
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'idée là dessus je
sais pas si vous avez le fait que les
dépenses augmentent moins vite que les
recettes
ça peut être aussi une règle de bonne
gestion pour rétablir progressivement
les équilibres mais de quelle façon
aussi on leur en contraignant et est ce
qu'un gouvernement peut sont exonérés
assez facilement finalement comme on
s'en est aperçu ces dernières années la
deuxième le deuxième point c'est plutôt
un point d accord mais ce n'était pas
favorable à la création du haut conseil
des finances publiques je ne reste
toujours pas favorable
je vois passer de la plus value qu'il a
pu apporter et pourquoi ne pas
transformer finalement la mission de la
cour des comptes pour que ce soit la
cour des comptes qui donne son point de
vue sur ce sujet en plus c'est le même
président donc que j'apprécie
particulièrement
mais mais en tout cas en tout cas
je me pose cette question de savoir
pourquoi pourquoi crée toujours des
organismes pourquoi les renforcer et
surtout je pense qu'en la matière c'est
le parlement qui devrait avoir la main
sur sur ces organismes en tout cas c'est
nous qui sommes une instance de contrôle
et c'est nous qui devrions avoir les
moyens d'avoir un contrôle plus strict
là dessus merci vincent jérôme bascher
puis didier rambaud
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues deux
éléments juridiques tout d'abord qu'est
ce que vous pourriez suggéré on
attendait peut-être un petit peu plus de
votre rapport sur les suggestions
juridique que ce soit au point de vue
européen vous avez dit qu' il était et
le lion européenne a reconnu un peu
obsolète
en tout cas tout le moins suspendu
qu'est ce que vous pourriez recommandé à
paolo gentiloni pour qu'ils puissent
satisfaire et la france et les pays
frugaux deuxième question du jour
juridique qu'il faut dire voir là lol
faut-il à te dire il règle d'or et
comment modifier suivant le paradigme
que vous avez exposé sur les recettes
qui devait progresser plus vite que les
dépenses
comment le traduire entre les crédits
évaluatif les crédits limitatif
deuxième question qui est ce plus de
techniques financières
là vous avez effectivement créé la cad s
mais je crois qu'il existait dix ans
auparavant la caisse de la dette
publique
la cdp nez qui servait à allah au moment
où dette arrive à échéance à la racheter
pour reprendre ce qui a était adepte ou
notamment plus élevé est ce que vous
croyez pas en reprenant la suggestion a
priori fait par le rusé le maire et de
dire quand on est sur un cyclo en est de
nouveau supérieur le cyclo deux
classiques du cycle économique
on pourrait y mettre mais surplus de
recettes du cycle pour pouvoir au moment
opportun et j'étais bien au moment
opportun racheter la dette à maturité
sur ce sujet que vous rappeliez lieu au
déroulement de la bête
une conclusion je me permettez moi je
crois surtout le problème c'est la
volonté politique de réduire la dépense
publique
et là c'est vrai que vous avez petite
impasse dans votre propos merci jérôme
didier rambaud puis 25 capo-canellas
merci président une remarque et deux
questions rapides
la première remarque effectivement on a
depuis plusieurs semaines dans notre
pays un débat sur comment rembourser
cette dette faute il vise haut les
fautes il l'attend au nez au départ j'ai
pris ça pour un exercice de sémantique
mais bon j'ai bien compris quelle était
la différence et vous avez clairement ce
matin confirmé que vous ne privilégier
pas l'option du cantonnement
effectivement je partage ce point de vue
parce que à mon avis les français ont
besoin de savoir faire la différence
entre ce qui relève de la dette
perpétuelle et qu'il faut continuer à
pouvoir réduire et celles qui relèvent
de la dette coheed qui deuxième question
qui concerne les règles budgétaires
européennes
là aussi je voudrais essayer j'ai essayé
de bien comprendre si pour vous vous
considérez que ces règles sont devenues
caduques ou inadaptées et on parle
beaucoup de l'idée de passer d'un pacte
de stabilité est un pacte de
soutenabilité qu'elle partagez vous ce
constat et enfin la troisième question
qui concerne l'avenir de la gestion des
finances publiques
on parle effectivement beaucoup aussi de
d'arriver à une distinction entre les
dépenses de fonctionnement et les
dépenses d'investissement
alors quand on est un élu local on sait
très bien faire la différence au niveau
des finances de l'état l'exercice me
paraît plus compliqué est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui est possible et
surtout pertinents merci merci didier
vincent capo-canellas puis stéphane soit
pareil
merci monsieur le président d'abord
merci au président arthuis bon j'ai
admiré la performance je crois qui il
n'a réussi que sa commission à se tenir
sur plusieurs lignes de crêtes à la fois
alors d'abord un je suis frappé quand
même par un chiffre qui est 80% la dette
française est mise en 2020 a été acheté
par les banques centrales vont alors
comment on peut me jouer avec ce constat
là parce que ce chiffre est parlant en
même temps il a un côté anesthésiant
parce que l'opinion peut dire dans ce
cas là a continué il faut peut-être que
on arrive à ré expliquer en quoi c'est
malgré tout un problématique est est ce
que ça veut vraiment dire que le marché
n'aurait pas acheté c'est d'être là et
que ça aurait eu des conséquences sur
les taux à court terme bon ça c'est une
première question
deuxièmement une question sur le niveau
d'ambition de vos propositions
alors première réaction on a un peu
tendance à se dire on attendait que ça
soit plus alarmistes et on entend
surtout un discours de méthode
bon alors je pensais pas la modestie
c'est surtout du réalisme et c'est une
bonne chose mais avec l'horizon 2030
125% du pipe bon finalement c'est son
parti donc vous nous y habituer un peu
aussi mais voilà est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas être plus
plus dynamique peut-être est plus
alarmiste et afficher plus d'objectif
sur la réduction des dépenses primaires
posé la question on nous dit souvent que
c'est pas la dépense de l'état en tant
que tels que c'est plutôt la sphère
sociale oui mais comment on fait dans ce
cas là j'aurais aimé que vous allez
peut-être un petit peu loin ceux là
dessus dernier point sur le débat sur la
voûte n'est aussi sur l'île de crète sur
dépenses d'avenir en vironnement talbot
est ce qu'on risque pas du coup de dire
oui on va faire des efforts mais alors
par contre la transition écologique et
les dépenses d'avenir là on va continuer
est ce qu'on va voir finalement tourner
en rond là dessus qu'on en sort de cette
équation là un peu solubles merci
vincent stéphane sotraval puis michel
canévet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques quelques remarques et deux ou
trois questions par rapport au travail
de votre commission que nous avait
présenté ce matin et dont je crois
l'important c'est est certaine à la fois
pour éclairer des décisions mais aussi
pour éclairer les français parce que le
je crois que les français sont très
inquiet de l'état de nos finances
publiques de la situation de la dette
peut-être paradoxalement beaucoup plus
que ce que les gouvernants ne le laisse
à voir jusqu alors et par rapport aux
trois piliers que vous nous avez
présenté la boussole la vigie et le
troisième qui est qui et l'invisibilité
ou la pédagogie
s'appuyant effectivement sur le
parlement qui est qui qui représente
l'ensemble des français je veux insister
sur ce sur ce point là parce que ce
travail de pédagogie et donc de bonne
compréhension de bon partage me semble
essentiel et je voulais donc insisté sur
deux points celui de cette dichotomie
effectivement entre dépenses
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
qui qui est difficile à régler
doudou d'où le choix de rester sur les
dépenses d'avenir
mais l'expérience nous montre on
retrouve toujours de bonnes raisons de
qualifier des dépenses de dépenses
d'avenir et que peut-être il
conviendrait d'aller un petit peu plus
loin pour fixer un cadre une règle on a
beaucoup évoqué les règles effectivement
de la gouvernance les règles européennes
mais les règles d'un cadre d'une
lisibilité de ce que seraient nos
dépenses d'investissement et de
fonctionnement puisque aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est un des points qui est
difficilement compréhensible par par nos
concitoyens sur la manière dont
effectivement l'état se financent
aujourd'hui financent son fonctionnement
depuis 1974 de manière déficitaire
deuxième deuxième sujet sur sur cette
même question pédagogique ce fameux
roulement de la dette
on n'avait pas évoqué l'allongement
éventuellement de la dette
est ce que c'est une solution possible
une réponse possible mais surtout est ce
que on est condamnés durablement
éternellement à ce roulement de la dette
et est donc aussi cette situation qui
paraît difficilement compréhensible pour
le commun des mortels en permanence de
réemprunter en fait le capital qu'on
doit échéance et on sait que nous avons
partir de 2023 des stocks très
conséquent à ce titre la voilà sur ces
deux points je vous remercie des
précisions que vous pourriez nous
apporter merci tf1 michel klein devait
depuis bernard delcros bien je voudrais
remercier le président jean arthuis des
observations qu'il a bien voulu nous
nous présenter et du travail qui a été
réalisé par la commission
effectivement constate que depuis
plusieurs décennies
nous avons été dans la capacité
d'équilibrer nos comptes publics
faut quand même en prendra que c'est se
demander comment cela sur un possible
dans les temps à venir dans la mesure où
pas nous avons des engagements
extrêmement fort
notre programmation pluriannuelle le
militaire par exemple qui amène à peu se
dépense la prochaine loi sur les
publique au développement qui le fera
pareil quand il ya eu au début de la
décennie précédente la volonté de
réduire les effectifs de de la fonction
publique on s'est trouvés affrontés il
ya des problèmes de sécurité et la
nécessité de réaugmenter le nombre de
policiers de gendarmes en fin de jeu au
niveau de la justice dont il ya des
besoins à peu près partout et en même
temps la nécessité de retrouver un
équilibre des finances publiques donc
comment peut-on faire est ce que par
exemple ne faudrait-il pas réussi à
instaurer une règle d'or parce que c'est
vrai que
comment obliger les gouvernements à
présenter des mesures d'équilibré ce que
c'est pas une règle d'or
constitutionnelle qui doit permettre d'y
aboutir prochaine des principales
questions je me pose là si michel
bernard delcros puis rémi féraud oui
merci
cherchant à tweed de votre présence ce
matin et s'échange sur un sujet
évidemment kg est extrêmement important
pour pour nous tous vous proposait de
définir un calcul annuel des dépenses
publiques associées à un plancher de
d'investissements d'avenir ne voulait
rappeler selon un principe simple il
faut que la croissance des dépenses soit
inférieure à la croissance des recettes
et disposez d'un compte sur des écarts
qui serait confiée à une institution
budgétaire indépendante
cette norme en dépenses telles que la
boule a qualifié se déclinerait sur
toutes les administrations publiques et
sur les collectivités locales par une
extension des contrats de cahors mais
vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs il existe
aujourd'hui un cadre financier
pluriannuel pour l'état qui la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
mais qui n'est pas respecté et donc se
pose la question et le sujet qu'à
évoquer mon collègue vincent de l'esa
pose la question du respect et
finalement de ce cadre pluri annuel des
dépenses publiques si un cadre encore
faute et se donner les moyens de pouvoir
le respecter alors envisagez-vous au
plus tôt est il possible même de rendre
cette norme en dépenses
contraignant si je reprends le moc est
évoqué une obligation de respect pour
l'état comme c'est le cas pour les
collectivités elle est contraignante
pour les collectivités parce que je
rappelle que dans les contrats de cahors
le maintien du niveau dotations de
l'état est directement liée au respect
de la hausse des dépenses de
fonctionnement donc y at-il une
possibilité de rendre ce cadre
contraignant pour l'étape
et puis j'ai une autre question sur les
collectivités dans votre rapport je
crois que c'est la page 52
vous indiquez la gestion publique
territoriale est toujours très éclatée
du fait de l'existence d'un très grand
nombre de collectivités territoriales et
vous comparer avec l'allemagne
pouvez vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
ce sujet et et avez vous des
propositions à faire
je vous remercie merci bernard rémi
féraud puis charles bonnet merci
monsieur le président et merci au
président arthuis d'être venu évidemment
nous présenter le rapport de la
commission c'est pour nous un travail
très intéressant et je pense en
particulier à la question de la méthode
parce que finalement nous sommes encore
dans la crise vous n'êtes pas allé sur
des solutions complètes mais sur la
méthode de la boussole de la vigie et
d'accorder plus d'importance au pilotage
budgétaire général notamment du
parlement je pense qu'il ya là des
pistes intéressantes je pense notamment
à ce troisième point de vos
recommandations ce troisième pilier
je dois dire moi-même depuis mon
élection comme parlementaire il ya trois
ans maintenant j'étais très surpris
qu'on passe tant de temps à la
discussion budgétaire
et si peu de temps et si peu d'attention
au contrôle de la réalisation de ce que
nous avons voté
c'est là une vieille tradition mais il
ya là je pense quand même un véritable
un véritable souci et je vois que vous
proposez une méthode pour travailler
autrement dans notre dans le cadre
parlementaire je pense que c'est
intéressant ceci dit je reste sceptique
sur la boussole est ce que vous pensez
véritablement possible que dans chaque
quinquennat dans les 100 premiers jours
soit adoptée une loi de programmation
des finances publiques sa part est un
délai très rapide est ce qu'on peut
estimer que c'est raisonnable ce soit
une priorité d'un nouveau président de
la république quel que soit d'ailleurs
sa couleur politique ça n'est pas là le
sujet mais voilà en terme en termes de
méthode et de rythme politique
deuxième question isolement cantonnement
un bien entendu votre votre appréciation
plutôt négative et je pense que c'est en
train de monter en ce moment sur la
notion de tamponnement mais a dans ce
cas là à quoi sert l'isolément à part en
méthodes statistiques enfin en
connaissance et est ce que c'est
possible de tôtes devra de mettre bien
en avant l' isolement sans passer
ensuite à un cantonnement qui d'ailleurs
cantonnement entraîne probablement une
hausse des prélèvements obligatoires
même si c'est dans le cadre des comptes
sociaux est justement j'en viens à ma
troisième question et c'est certainement
le point de désaccord que j'ai le plus
fort avec votre approche c'est d'être
resté très orthodoxe en maintenant un
tabou sur les recettes
hier maîtrise des dépenses publiques
tout en disant d'ailleurs qu'il ne
serait pas raisonnable de les réduire
brutalement mais avec un vrai tabou sur
les recettes à un moment où on voit par
exemple la nouvelle administration
américaine parle d'augmenter le taux de
l'impôt sur les sociétés aux états unis
est-ce que c'est pas le moment de
changer de paradigme et de voilà de
réfléchir aussi aux recettes ça peut
être aussi sur leurs structures et pas
seulement sur leur niveau général est
donc si c'est leur sur leur structure
sur leur dynamique possible parce que
deux gouvernements au gouvernement de
quinquennat en quinquennat finalement la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques elle est
bien réelle pas la diminution mais la
maîtrise la volonté de ne pas augmenter
les impôts
également et du coup ce sont les
déficits publics qui ne diminuent pas il
n'y a pas vraiment de stabilisateurs
automatiques en période de reprise et on
arrive aux limites de cet exercice
aujourd'hui pas je pense qu'il faut
qu'on travaille aussi sur la question
des rôles scène des angles merci rémi ce
président tout va bien
quand le 45e et le 44e il dit pour
l'instant ça va bien je veux dire nous
allons on est à la moitié des
interventions et des questions je vous
propose de poursuivre parce que si
jamais on coupait vous risqueriez déjà
ne répondent quasiment à toutes les
questions mais je reconnais que
l'exercice devient des fichiers par
contre vous avez une chance on vous
demandera pas de citer nommément chacun
des intervenants et donc de faire une
réponse est non et donc de faire des
réponses globales
reprenons l'ensemble des sujets
évidemment je sens que l'exercice n'est
pas si simple que ça charles bonnet puis
éric bocquet
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre est ravie de vous retrouver
dans cette configuration
je voudrais m'arrêter et me consacrer à
la gouvernance qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé dans mon temps vos travaux et
je trouve que d'exercice et c'est assez
bon mais je me demande s'il va assez
loin et je veux parler de son
appropriation démocratique et plus
précisément de la nécessaire adhésion du
parlement et des collectivités locales
contrairement à l'allemagne poussé la
recette qui détermine la procédure
budgétaire et où la dépense est
réellement soumise aux deux chambres est
où le bundesrat arbitres des ressources
des collectivités locales
et cela suivant des règles
institutionnelles beaucoup plus
contraignante que l'europe
en réalité le débat budgétaire est
présenté par l'exécutif ont quasi
totalité aussi je crains que
l'institution du duo conseil des
finances publiques en organe un
organisme indépendant de prévision et de
contrôle même aux mains du parlement et
une conférence nationale en début de
mandature avec des collectivités de
qu'elle ne soit à un cadre insuffisant
pour notre pays
en effet le fait que les collectivités
locales perçoivent aujourd'hui une très
large part
d'impôts nationaux que le système actuel
les déconnectent quasiment du sort de la
dette nationale à laquelle elle estime
d'ailleurs est étrangère que le
parlement non seulement aux subissent la
loi de finances mais soit également
écarté des négociations que l'exécutif
entame au coup par coup avec les
collectivités locales n'existe pas
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans une
nouvelle gouvernance systémique pérenne
pour atteindre une culture qu'on
essentielle est véritablement efficace
merci charles aussi vont avec et reebok
et puis sophie tripoli ont failli merci
monsieur le président j'ai eu de brefs
moments de l'espoir lecture de votre
rapport monsieur le président
quelques secondes la première quand vous
dites écarté l'austérité on ne peut
qu'applaudir à cette formulation et
accroître les paires au gatt yves du
parlement j'en convient tout à fait nous
sommes insuffisamment associé cette
histoire de dettes et même des finances
publiques
mais vous dites il ne faut pas s'engager
dans un programme de réduction des
dépenses dès maintenant et c'est le thé
maintenant qui m'inquiète
dès lors que vous écarter tout nouvel
impôt enfin vous le gouvernement
j'entends c'était la commande de votre
rapport
en gros aucune alternative donc on
revient au fameux tina des années 80 il
n'y a pas d'alternative
la seule voie possible est douce et la
maîtrise des dépenses et j'ai ici le
rapport pébereau de 2005 qui eut la même
mission en son temps et 10è et 11è
proposition faire de la réduction des
dépenses inefficaces la priorité du
gouvernement et du parlement pendant la
phase de retour à l'équilibré c'était il
ya saison on exactement dans le même
dans le même cadre et pourtant cette
dépense publique a été l'un des leviers
si ce n'est le levier principal pour
éviter l'effondrement complet de
l'économie et même de la société
j'irai jusque là alors sur la dette vous
dites la dette c'est l'accumulation des
déficits annuels
puis depuis 46 ans mais un budget c'est
aussi des recettes effectivement or ce
point recette n'est pas du tout évoqué
dans le rapport ont alors qu'il ya eu
des gagnants dans cette crise il ya
quand même eu des gagnants
on peut parler des gaffes en peut parler
de la grande distribution des assureurs
etc et on est toujours sur la
problématique de mettre dans sur le même
plan un état et un ménage vis-à-vis de
la dette alors que ça n'est pas
comparable chacun le sait parce que sur
les recettes
on pourrait aussi imaginer une analyse
fine de tout ce qui est exonérations
dégrèvement les raisons fiscales qui
reste un sujet les niches
voilà autant de sujets qu'il faudrait je
crois examiner de près pour avoir une
analyse un peu plus équilibrée des
matière budgétaire sur les alternatives
en matière de gestion d'être le rapport
pas je trouve assez rapidement sans
véritablement qui est une démonstration
alors vous dites quand même vous nous
les avons finalement écarté ces options
et c'est à dire qu'ils jettent à l'eau
un débat au sein de la commission sur
ces aspects vous dites là la dette
valeur le cantonnement où la dette
perpétuelle ou l'annulation
inquièteraient les marchés financiers
qui ne sont nullement inquiet
aujourd'hui on le constate avec des taux
négatifs qu'il nous propose
et même dans certains cas un endettement
à 50 ans ce qui est tout à fait nouveau
donc pas d'inquiétude de ce côté là donc
débat sur la tête vous dit dans le
rapport et c'est vrai une écrasante
majorité des français considère en effet
qu'ils sont mal informés sur la d public
je pense qu'effectivement c'est l'un des
enjeux du débat démocratique du moment
les règles 0 pnl ont explosé c'est
évident tant du point de vue des
déficits que du niveau d'endettement y
compris des beaucoup de pays de l'ue du
bloc européen sont devenues caduques
mais quelles propositions feriez-vous en
matière d'évolution des règles
européennes
n'est ce pas le moment de revoir
fondamentalement le mandat de la bce qui
a d'ailleurs joué un rôle nouveau depuis
plusieurs années avant même cette crise
decaux vide
avec l'assouplissement quantitatif les
mesures non conventionnelles
elle est sorti de son cadre est-ce qu'on
peut pas réfléchir à lui faire jouer un
autre rôle en termes d'interventions
directes
la réserve fédérale américaine la fed la
banque d'angleterre dès le mois d'avril
2001 l'a fait directement financement
des états je pense qu'il ya matière à
débat sur le sur le sujet finalement le
rapport retient comme objectif central
de faire baisser le niveau de la dette à
partir de 2030 en limitant la croissance
des dépenses mika 0 65 % par an en
volume
nous étions à 1,3 en objectifs en
moyenne entre 2009 et 2019 donc réduire
les dépenses publiques
l ag rejoindre jérôme bascher lesquels
concrètement l'hôpital l'éducation la
justice
le niveau des retraites etc si on veut
aller jusqu'au bout alors dernière
remarque boussole vigie compteur moi
j'avais l'impression déjà que dans ce
pays on avait tout un tableau de bord
pour gérer les finances publiques
merci merci eric sauces y est allé pour
lyon merci hervé maurey merci monsieur
le président merci pour pour la
présentation et les échanges
d'ailleurs on voit que les collègues
s'interrogent sur ces nouvelles règles
qui pourraient assurer l'objectif de
stabilité de l'endettement de notre pays
en se disant le problème on se fixe des
règles mais on ne les applique pas mais
peut-être que si on les applique pas
c'est parce que tout simplement elle ne
sont pas applicables pourquoi parce
qu'elles font l'impasse sur une certaine
forme de soutenabilité démocratique
on parle beaucoup de faire accepter
l'acceptation sociale de règles
contraignantes et tant qu'on ne se pose
pas la question de la prise en compte
des questions d'urgence sociale
d'urgence climatique pour faire en sorte
que des règles que nous mettrions face à
nous soit acceptable socialement soit
acceptable démocratiquement nous serons
dans la situation est bien où elles
seront de fait inapplicable
alors moi je ne suis pas favorable à une
sorte de technicisation dépolitisation
de la gestion budgétaire mais bien au
contraire d'une solution qui permette
de convaincre les citoyens et les
citoyennes et en fonction de la réalité
sociale qu'ils vivent à ce titre
effectivement je regrette et je
m'inspirerai du terme que le président
reynal à utiliser dans la note qui l'a
envoyé pour contribuer aux travaux de
cette commission
je regrette le désarmement fiscale qu'il
qu'il induit quid aujourd'hui des
dépenses des baisses de fiscalité qui
sont aujourd'hui prévus ou qui ont été
décidés très très récemment
je pense bien sûr aux 20% les plus
élevés de la taxe d'habitation ou encore
de la décision très récente de baisse
des impôts de production qui vont dans
les années à venir générer des baisses
de recettes qu'il faudra bien compenser
alors comment les pompes en serons nous
moi je crois qu'il faut revenir sur ses
décisions
parce que sinon nous les compenseront
pas les baisses des dépenses publiques
mais qu'est ce que c'est à dire que nous
allons baisser les dépenses publiques si
ce n'est une façon un peu moins un peu
moins effrayante un peu plus délicate de
dire que nous allons baisser les
dépenses sociales et d'ailleurs on le
voit on observe aujourd'hui dès à
présent puisqu'on part de la dette de
l'unedic qui est nettement alourdie
notamment par le chômage partiel
en faisant payer les précaires c'est à
dire qu'on paye on fait payer la
protection des salariés par les plus
précaires n'est ce pas là quelque chose
de proprement inacceptable au fond de
nos de nos de notre de nos devise
républicaine d'égalité et de fraternité
enfin je m'interroge très très fortement
sur la question évidemment de notre
capacité à investir au niveau des
besoins concernant l'urgence climatique
eye for six chiffres at entre 10 et 30
milliards d'euros par an les besoins
d'investissements pour répondre à nos
propres engagements aux engagements que
nous avons souscrit
peut-être que lie à la matière à mettre
en oeuvre des règles des règles qui
garantissent le fait que ces
investissements soient prêts soient
réalisés pas au détriment de la justice
sociale à mon sens est comment faire
aujourd'hui pour inciter au niveau
européen un verdissement de la politique
monétaire qui serait je pense d'ailleurs
un instrument important je mens arrête
là je vous remercie de votre attention
merci sophy hervé maurey
terrine qu'eric aux inc merci monsieur
le président je dois d'abord dire
présents reçus tout le plaisir que j'ai
à le retrouver dans cette maison
beaucoup de choses ont été dites je
partage bien sûr les analyses les
constats les objectifs qui ont été
présentés par le présent article
je m'interroge davantage sur sur les
moyens et notamment sur la capacité de
faire en sorte que cette loi
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
elles soient respectés on sait tous
qu'il y à un certain nombre de lois de
programmation qui existent notamment
dans le domaine de la défense et ne sont
jamais respectées
on sait tous que les lois de finances
qui sont annuelles en général ne sont
eux mêmes pas respecté c'est pour ça
qu'on a des lois de finances
rectificatives même les années ordinaire
donc je veux jouer savoir comment le
présent arthuis imaginer sa commission
comment il imagine que c'est cette loi
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
pour être respecté pourquoi elle le
serait celle là et pas les autres
et comment elle le serait et je suis un
petit peu étonné connaissant les
positions du produit qui soit parlé un
petit peu plus loin en proposant par
exemple une règle d'or dont je l' ai
entendu parler jadis naguère qui aurait
pu être inscrite dans notre constitution
je vois pas comment sans ce type de
dispositif on pourrait arriver à avoir
vraiment des gouvernants verture matière
de finances publiques
je rappelle qu'il ya des règles et on le
sait tous ici beaucoup plus
contraignantes qui s'appliquent aux
collectivités locales
pourquoi l'état n'accepte rai il pas lui
aussi d'avoir des règles un peu plus
contraignantes que celles qui qui existe
aujourd'hui et puis dernière question
question subsidiaire quel sort va selon
vous c'est le président connaître ce
rapport par rapport aux intentions du
gouvernement
ça commençait bien bon
thierry thierry cozic puis patrice joly
merci monsieur le président merci au
président arthuis de cet échange
extrêmement intéressant je voulais
revenir sur sur le sur la soutenabilité
de la dette et les investissements
d'avenir
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui malgré la
crise sanitaire on constate que les taux
d'emprunt fallait les taux d'intérêt
auxquels la france emprunte aujourd'hui
sont très faibles voire négatifs
notamment sur des échéances à 15 ans en
gros ça signifie qu'aujourd'hui les
investisseurs sont prêts à payer à
l'état pour pouvoir lui prêter de
l'argent
c'est vrai quel que soit les ratios
aussi effrayant qu'on peut présenter à
la population la question du déficit et
de la dette ne semble pas dans
l'immédiat suscité le plus
d'interrogations
la vraie question qui est posée n'était
n'est donc pas de définir une
trajectoire de finances publiques mais
plutôt de résoudre une problématique qui
moi me paraît bien plus compliqué en
effet dans un contexte aujourd'hui
d'épuisement et des gains de
productivité et donc du potentiel de
croissance ne faut-il pas inverser les
priorités pour faire de la soutenabilité
écologique et social le coeur de
l'action publique
si à l'échéance de la dette qui est
contracté aujourd'hui l'économie
française est ravagée à la fois par les
inégalités et des désastres écologiques
et sanitaires qui serait mal anticipé la
dette pourrait devenir une vraie
difficulté et elle peut l'être si on la
place avant cette soutenabilité et donc
mais ma question
en d'autres termes c'est aujourd'hui la
priorité doit être de garantir la seule
valise la solvabilité de l'état coûte
que coûte qui elle ne me paraît pas en
danger mais plutôt de garantir la
pérennité et la stabilité de la société
merci thierry patrice joly puisse sylvie
vermeillet je vais reprendre
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues je vais reprendre
une formulation dont je vous indiquerai
quel est l'auteur qui essaient sinon la
dette publique n'est pas un fardeau
c'est juste de l'amener émise par l'état
dans la poche des gens et des
entreprises
j'ajouterai des financiers
malheureusement des spéculateurs et qui
n'est pas récupérée par l'impôt alors
cette formulation en fête est celle de
stéphanie calton qui appartient à une
école économique américaine et qui est
en train qui vient d'éditer enfin
d'europe de publier un ouvrage s'appelle
le mythe du déficit et aux éditions les
liens qui libèrent
rien que le nom de l'éditeur donne un
peu d'air sur les perspectives et
peut-être l'élargissement du champ de
notre réflexion et c'est une école qui
formulent 7 quiero questionne en fait
l'ensemble des paradigmes qui sont les
mieux ancrées dans le en matière
économique et qui vise à essayer de
trouver des solutions pour trouver les
ressources ont regardé transition que
nous avons à financer d'autres avant moi
l'ont évoqué et donc ça me conduit à me
questionner aussi sur l'idée d'avoir une
instance indépendante qui fixerait un
peu les cadres de ce qu'est qu'on serait
considéré comme étant de la bonne
gestion de la bonne gestion budgétaire
je pense qu'au contraire dans la perdrix
qu'elles ont des goûts en fait
l'ensemble des des repères que nous
avions sont bousculés il vaut mieux
favoriser la concentration pour trouver
les nouvelles voix qui nous permettent
de
de de poursuivre en tout cas les
transitions dans lesquelles nous sommes
nécessairement engagé qui vont
nécessiter des moyens importants et je
retire revient également sur par rapport
à ce que disait un certain nombre de
collègues sur l'idée qu' en matière de
gestion budgétaire de stratégie
budgétaire d'orientation je pense que le
parlement et seul le parlement est
légitime pour les fixer devrait revenir
ce revient sur des schémas un peu plus
classique concernant donc l'approché de
la gestion de la dette ça a évoqué
monsieur le ministre était clément les
perspectives en matière de dépenses mais
moi aussi comme d'autres je pense que la
question des recettes est essentiel il y
a là des possibilités de financement à
trouver à la fois à travers l'évasion la
fraude fiscale c'est évoqué à travers
également la fiscalisation d'un certain
nombre d'activités aujourd'hui et voyez
ce que j'ai en tête qui ne soit pas
suffisant ce ce fiscalisés et qui
n'apportent pas une contribution
suffisante au fonctionnement notre
société et puis derrière ça il ya
surtout la question de la justice
fiscale c'est un élément important de
l'acceptation des prélèvements et
surtout aujourd'hui on voit bien que
cette injustice fiscale est un élément
de dilution de notre démocratie est le
dernier point je voudrais avoir votre
avis si vous me le permettez le seul
ministre sur ce que vous pensez des
règles de bonne gestion je pense en
particulier ou 3 et aux 60% du pib dont
on parle depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies avoir votre avis sur les
fondements scientifiques de ses ratios
et si tenté qu'il y en ait d'autres à à
comment à déterminer sur quels
fondements scientifiques on pourrait
s'appuyer je remercie la sénatrice
sylvie vermeille et puis christian
bilhac merci monsieur le président
devrait tout d'abord saluer et remercier
le président arthuis pour la qualité du
cadre qu'il nous propose et puis toute
la sagesse qu'il ajoute à sa
présentation
j'aurai deux
deux interrogations la première qui
rejoint celle de nombre de mes collègues
concernant les collectivités
comment est ce que vous imaginez
monsieur le président l'éventuelle
efforts à produire par les collectivités
autre ado au delà du contrat de cahors
et dès lors est ce que la notion de
libre administration aurait encore du
sens et puis le deuxième point vous avez
énoncé la production en début de
législature
l'énoncé d'une loi pluriannuelle des
finances publiques est ce que vous
imaginez sereinement la réforme des
retraites se caler dans la prochaine
législature rapidement merci merci
sylvie christian bilhac puis d'un sens -
merci monsieur le brûlant arthuis
je suis un nouveau sénateur et dont je
n'ai pas tous les codes de cette maison
mais je croyais que les bugs équilibre
financier était une évidence et je vous
rejoins comme vous dites que 3% moi ça
me surprend moi personnellement je gérer
une collectivité comme la plupart ici et
nos bus j'ai osé voté en équilibre avec
du déficit et je suis un peu gêné quand
même déjà par le pack de cahors et par
la province n'a pas de corps
parce que finalement on retrouve jean de
la fontaine la cigale et la fourmi
ainsi l'état cigales qui va demander à
fourmies collectivités de participer aux
adresses ceux qui ont toujours fait
preuve de rigueur qui ont toujours
rembourser leurs dettes comme toujours
terminé avait des comptes administratifs
en excédent m'a alors demandé de venir
secourir la cigale à cacheter tous les
témoins je reviendrai sur eux également
la soutenabilité sociale
de cet équilibre il faut quand même posé
parce que si en allemagne on a toujours
considéré toute la classe politique que
c'était l'inflation qui avait amené et
les arts pouvoir on voit bien
aujourd'hui partout que même si les
faits sont les jugulaires eh bien on a
une montée des populismes clip pour ma
part m'inquiète je parle que ses clients
de partager la cette assemblée
et moi je rejoins victor hugo quand il
disait dans son discours de la misère
que l'homme est méchant mais pourquoi la
border fatale l'homme est malheureux et
donc trône en garde à la soutenabilité
sociale quand même parce que nous avons
une vraie menace au delà de l'équilibré
financier me lâche sociétales et
politiques qui nous guette
non je revienne à l'équilibré je
partagerai vous les limites de la
politique du rabot
on a raboté alors moi je constate que
son rabot il ne doit pas bien taillée
parce que malgré des coups de rabot
depuis les définir le déficit est
toujours là et je me pose la question et
je vous pose la question ne faudrait pas
trop changer d'outil est passé du rabot
à la scie mais qu'est ce qu'on va signer
qu'est-ce qu'on va s'y est toute la
question est là le croit je pense pour
ma part je vous demande ce que vous en
pensez
tout d'abord s'il ne faut pas recentré
la dépense publique d'état sur les
missions régaliennes et voir alors
appelé chat nouvel atelier
centralisation on peut appeler ça un
contrat mais voir sur ne pourrait pas
confié
pourquoi l'activité publique qu'un su
gérer dans certains domaines et je pense
au collège au lycée en particulier aux
écoles ou des efforts prodigieux ont été
faits par les collectivités je n'aurais
pas fait les tâches et avec réserve et
la coupe étage est-ce que c'est pas la
solution
et puis je conclurai en m'interrogeant
sur la pluriannualité vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le président ce
contrat pluriannuel ses plans plus rien
n'est jamais respectée
d'une part on peut toujours se faire
plaisir et d'autre part n'y at-il pas un
risque dans un monde en perpétuel
mouvement monde en évolution
que s'il était respecté pour innover ce
soit un corps c'est qu'un pet shop et
d'évoluer voilà je les questions qui me
viennent à l'esprit
je n'ai terminé merci christian vincent
segouin m
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le président j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'intérêt
alors je vais pas revenir sur la dépense
qu'il faudrait maîtriser dorénavant dans
l'avenir je voulais surtout revenir sur
votre propos introductif vous vous dites
vous écrivez que la chute de la
croissance économique reflète en partie
une chute de compétitivité de la france
on a souscrit des plans de relance tant
européens que français or j'étais
surpris de voir dans votre analyse que
ces plans de relance n'ont pas d'effet
ou des effets qui sont nuls puisque vous
dites que le rattrapage de l'année 2019
ne sera pas avant 2023 2024 si je ne
trompe pas et que le taux de croissance
va rester à un point cinq au maximum de
vos prévisions pour les années à venir
donc est-ce que ce plan de relance où on
devait rapatrier des entreprises est un
leurre ou est ce que il aura des effets
que vous n'avez pas calculer merci
vincent merci à vous tous d'avoir tenu
le temps ce qui me permet de poser une
ode aux questions complémentaires
[Musique]
du tout du tout du tout mais en
complément petit peu de ce que vous avez
dit mes chers collègues en ce qui me
concerne
vous avez évoqué dans votre d'autres
rapports de l'idée de sanctuariser un
niveau plancher de dépenses d'avenir
afin de les préserver des efforts de
redressement à venir cette formulation
de niveau plancher m'a un peu gêné et
jugez plutôt une vision différente c'est
que est-ce qu'il faut pas profiter de
cette période de taux bas
donc je pense personnellement et après
audition bien sûr de l'ensemble des
intervenants qu'elle va durer un petit
peu pour des raisons que vous avez
évoqué d'ailleurs de masse monétaire
d'epargne aujourd'hui disponibles pour
finalement assumé un financement par la
dette d'une hausse des dépenses d'avenir
qui seraient favorables à la croissance
et cette croissance générant des
conditions pour son remboursement
en réalité derrière cette phrase ça se
pose la question de la défense de la
qualité de la dépense
en fait c'est plus une question
financière c'est plus une question de
qualité de dépenses que l'on pourrait
voir comme ceci vous avez vous avez dit
que vous avez été chargé de réaliser
différents scénarios en vous appuyant
sur des hypothèses réalistes
cela étant dit vous avez fait des
projections certaines projections sont
fondées sur une remontée du coût de
financement de la de la france à 3% 2027
alors qu'ils sont joe des nuls nous
l'avons déjà dit mais qu' aucun aucun
économiste
aucun marché aucune représentation de
l'avenir ne se situe une possibilité ou
en risque à 3,1 pour cent en 2027
les conjoncturistes table plutôt sur
alors certains sera 08 les marchés les
conjoncturistes plutôt à 1,4
on peut se tromper on peut mettre des
marques de précaution on est d'accord
mais si on axe sur des sur des
précautions trop grand
finalement est-ce qu'on se prive pas de
capacité à intervenir et je voulais vous
indiquer si finalement ce scénario
n'était pas une certaine volonté de
dédramatiser un peu la situation pour
amener à bouger est-ce que c'est pas un
peu trop fort comme comme vision et
enfin le troisième sujet a été évoqué
par sofitel et polluants qui m'a si tu
es donc je la félicite et remercie
d'abord delà d'avoir lu avec un
excellent document mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que le ministre j'étais là
évidemment vous le savez lorsque la
mission vous a été confiée dans la
première réunion avec le rapporteur
général et on a bien compris que le
ministre vous donner une mission de
résoudre des choses mais sans toucher à
rien enfin je veux dire par là il
fallait pas d'inflation il fallait pas
d'impôts il fallait pas le truc bois la
sortie c'est sûr que c'est bien
d'arriver à produire en rapport
parce que je veux dire que tous les
verrous ont été mis de manière contraire
en tout cas beaucoup de verrous ont été
mis mais cela étant dit moi je considère
et vous l'indiqué d'ailleurs que pour ce
qui va ce qui fait vraiment vraiment
être important c'est de dépenser
utilement pour l'avenir pour le
verdissement et c'est à ceux ci est
évoquée mais finalement on revient pas
sur les décisions qui ont été prises
cette année pour cette année et qui sont
curieuses parce que tout le monde les
critiques mais en creux c'est à dire le
gouverneur de la banque de france c'est
à dire le premier président de la cour
des comptes qui indique simplement que
c'est curieux en période de crise et de
crise comme on n'en a jamais connue
c'est des produits de diminuer les
recettes voit la donne et à se priver de
recettes en pleine période de crise on
peut admettre c'est pas mon avis que les
impôts de production ce soit un enjeu
pourquoi pas mais quand on est en
croissance mais quand on est en période
de crise
se priver de 10 milliards d'euros vous
essayez de protéger un peu cette
décision par trois phrases 3 trois
lignes dans le rapport sincèrement je ne
le comprends pas d'autant plus qu'il ne
s'agit pas là
choix d'investissement mais de
distribuer à tout le monde
des capacités dont on ne sait pas quoi
elle va être utilisée finalement le côté
industriel donc en désaccord total de la
même façon etait-il nécessaire ne
pouvons pas retarder les 20% de dh alors
ici j en aurais beaucoup de regrets les
uns et les autres jeux l'homme combien
mais quand même tu avais pas d'urgence à
avoir cette récupération et là aussi un
moment où nous dit que les gens qui ont
le plus de ressources
finalement on ne sait pas comment leur
faire sortir les économies et les
remettre dans le circuit mais une bonne
façon de les garder c'était de les
garder au niveau de l'état au passage
les jeunes terminent par là ça faisait à
peu près 17 milliards d'euros sur dix
ans je vous trouvez tout de suite le
remboursement de la crise voilà c'est
dommage que cela était proposé
merci monsieur monsieur le président
vous avez devant vous très exactement 34
minutes pour répond
d'éviter de mettre de la pression sur
mes épaules au moment où je dois
répondre à chacun d'entre vous c'est ce
que j'ai compris mes de revenir sur les
différents thèmes qui ont été bloqués
par les uns et les autres
d'abord je voudrais vous dire
et en cela je réponds à monsieur le
rapporteur général que nous sommes
interdits de nous substituer à la
décision politique c'est à dire que les
élections légitimes
un projet et ceux et celles qui auront
pour charge de le mettre en oeuvre ce
que nous avons voulu c'est nous placer
au niveau de la méthode des instruments
plusieurs parmi vous avez évoqué la
règle d'or règle d'or qui dans la
constitution poserait un principe dont
le conseil constitutionnel aurait à
vérifier qu'il est respecté nous sommes
posé cette question
et finalement nous avons pensé que pour
modifier la constitution il faut un
investissement d'énergie politique dont
on n'est jamais sûr et qu'il ira à son
terme dans le sens que nous souhaitons
dans les rapports multiples que vous
avez évoqué sur la dette car j'ai bien
conscience que l'exercice auquel nous
sommes livrés a été précédée par un
certain nombre de rapports dont les
enseignements n'ont pas toujours été
respectée et poserait je dire que deux
c'est mon expérience ici on a fait
beaucoup de rapports je me souviens d'un
rapport que je dont j'étais le
rapporteur sur les 35 heures à l'époque
en utilisant bain ou un rapport de cette
nature pourrait essayer de mesurer les
conséquences budgétaires conséquences en
termes de compétitivité économique et
et d'équilibré des comptes publics
l'impact sur les budgets de la santé par
exemple mans mais on peut pas dire que
ce type de rapports soient
systématiquement pris en considération
ont multiplié rapport mais on passe pas
à l'acte donc nous nous avons essayé de
définir quelques principes et s'agissant
de la règle d'or
j'ai souvenir que monsieur quand dessus
dans son rapport avait proposé
effectivement une modification de la
constitution
les deux assemblées l'avait approuvée
mais à l'époque le président de la
république avait fait le compte des voix
qui se manifesterait au congrès et il en
manquait quelques unes pour pouvoir
présenter ce projet de réforme est donc
ça n'a pas abouti
mais si vous pensez de main mais qu'il y
a une chance d'obtenir un accord au plan
constitutionnel
il a vraiment je vous encourage ray dans
cette voie mais je vous mets en garde
contre le fait que quand c'est dans la
constitution on a on introduit un
élément extrêmement rigide et quand vous
avez une crise comme celle que nous
traversons il faut une hesketh closes
comme le prix wolf des traités européens
car sinon ça marche pas donc on peut
prévoir toutes les règles
constitutionnelles que que l'on veut
mais si derrière il n'y a pas une
adhésion populaire
c'est derrière il n'y a pas une
révolution culturelle
et s'il n'y a pas une appropriation des
enjeux par les français eux-mêmes parce
que un état surendetté est il un état
totalement indépendant
pensez vous que monsieur de sipera ce
premier ministre grec au mois de juin
il ya sur la table un protocole imposé
par les créanciers
je suis aussi brasse ne veut pas le
ratifier
et pour donner de la force
à son opposition il organise un
référendum le peuple grec lui donne
raison à 66% et une suivante plus tard
monsieur cipra signent le protocole dire
que quand on parle des finances
publiques de son équipe de leur
équilibre et de la dette publique
on parle aussi la souveraineté alors
quand on est un des tags comme les états
unis d'amérique
on peut on peut émettre de la dette le
président peut engager un programme de
1900 milliards c'est plus facile quand
vous avez un niveau de dépense publique
qui est autour de 40% que lorsque vous
êtes à 56%
car nous nous avons saturer nos marges
de manoeuvre et c'est ça notre problème
est par ailleurs l'europe n'est pas un
état et donc il n'ya pas de dettes
européennes hormis celle qui va être
lancée par la commission pour les 750
milliards du plan de relance et de
résilience c'est une addition de dettes
souveraines nationale et ceci est une
distinction particulière
on peut certainement dépenser plus
émettre de la monnaie avec la complicité
la bienveillance des banques centrales
et si on est un état si on est un état
fédéral et il sans doute faut-il faut-il
y réfléchir mais nous sommes en europe
nous nous avons l'euro comme bouclier et
nous devons prendre en compte les
positions nos partenaires et c'est ça
qui complique la tâche alors vous m'avez
interrogèrent désormais 60% 3% qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
moi j'ai souvenir que 3 % et 60 %
c'était à une époque où les taux
d'intérêt étaient de 5 % à peu près et
100% de 60% ça fait 3 % autrement dit
c'était une façon de poser le principe
que les dépenses primaires devaient et l
équilibre et que c'est la charge de la
dette et qui devait représenter les 3%
c'est le souvenir que j'en ai
c'est à dire pour autant que c'est
intelligent suis pas sûr mais le
problème est qu'elle était le problème
le problème c'est que quand on passe à
la mode est unique on partage une
souveraineté mais c'est la seule
souveraineté qu'on est partagé l'europe
c'est un marché unique et c'est une
souveraineté monétaire la banque
centrale européenne et d'essence fédéral
mais ya pas de gouvernement européens et
donc comment faire vivre une monnaie
orpheline d'état la france négocié la
possibilité d'avoir un gouvernement
économique financier et budgétaire mais
les pays du nord de l'europe et
notamment l'allemagne n'en voulait pas
dans la crainte qu'ils avec les pays du
sud fasse marcher la planche à billets
et des visions de dette publique et
d'inflation éventuel vous l'avez rappelé
les allemands ont une phobie absolue de
l'inflation les années les années des
années des années 20 politique
la république de weimar et puis
l'ascension d'hitler
donc ils sont complètement hostile à
toute idée d' inflation puisque on ne
pouvait pas avoir un gouvernement
économique financier et budgétaire et un
budget européen pour réguler leur la
zone euro alors on a fait un règlement
de copropriété et c'est le pacte de
stabilité et de croissance qui n'a pas
fonctionné formidablement parce que
entre nous soit dit à l'époque les
comptes publics étaient souverainement
sincère y compris les comptes grecs et
on s'est aperçu que j'avais peut-être à
y voir de plus près mais au fond chacun
était un peu complice puisque ça ne
valait pas d'exporter des travaux
publics des systèmes d'armes vers la
grèce et quand on a vu que les grecs
étaient surendettées on s'est demandé où
étaient les créanciers il était en
allemagne il était en france donc ça n'a
pas fonctionné formidablement cette
gouvernance raconter simplement est le
vrai sujet corps à l'europe c'est quel
budget pour la zone euro et quel
gouvernement pour la zone euro mais le
rla vous poser une question fondamentale
qui appelle une révision des traités et
nous a pas échappé que les traités sont
révisées à l'unanimité et on n'y est pas
encore
donc ce que vous proposons c'est des
méthodes et des principes plus
pragmatique mais vous pouvez poser tous
les principes que vous voulez toutes les
règles que vous voulez y compris dans la
constitution s'il n'ya pas politiquement
une volonté et vous êtes le parlement et
quels sont vos contributions pour faire
baisser les dépenses alors nous nous
sommes abstenus de donner des
indications car ce n'était pas notre
mission ne vont pas nous substituer à la
volonté politique qui est tranchée à
l'occasion des élections
nous souhaitons simplement que les
français s'emparent de cette
problématique budgétaire
peut-être pour exercer une pression sur
les acteurs politiques et sur les
partenaires sociaux également nous ont
quand même des facteurs de conservatisme
assez fort nous sommes un pays hyper
centralisé hyper administrés ce qui
suppose des contrôles à tous les étages
dans une espèce de climat de méfiance au
surplus donc est ce que vous pensez
qu'on est prêt parce que on règle pas
les problèmes uniquement avec des
crédits budgétaires
nos problèmes sont pour l'essentiel des
problèmes de gouvernance
c'est vrai pour toute institution si les
principes de gouvernance ont bien posé
on peut avoir de l'efficacité mais si on
veut concilier tout et le contraire de
tout ce ça commence à être très
compliqué on a parlé de la santé par
exemple est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
uniquement une question de crédit moi je
préside un conseil du surveillance d'un
hôpital public les principes de
gouvernance pour un directeur d'hôpital
c'est pas évident il a aucune prise sur
les praticiens il ya d'un côté la
médecine de ville de l'autre côté
l'hôpital public est ce que de temps en
temps par territoire il faudrait pas
mettre un peu de coordination dans tout
cela pour obtenir un peut-être une plus
grande efficacité et donc qu'il n'ya pas
que des problèmes de gouvernance
budgétaire il ya aussi des problèmes
globalement de gouvernance alors sans
doute faut-il aller vers plus de
décentralisation de déconcentration
c'est préoccupant quand pour assurer la
vaccination il faut un protocole de 60
tâche pratiquement 11
est ce que les acteurs locaux ne
pourrait pas assumer des responsabilités
donc plus de marge de liberté mais sur
ces terrains là nous n'avons pas pu
avancer car c'était pas notre mission et
nous n'avons pas voulu nous nous
substituer aux politiques et je vous
rappelle que nous étions 10 et que
l'objectif c'était d'être 10 au moment
de la conclusion
donc il a fallu que chacun ait posé des
questions sur le niveau de l'impôt nous
sommes posé ces questions aussi mais
très franchement même prêtables irles
isf par exemple c'est quoi ces trois
milliards
c'est sans rapport avec les problèmes
que nous avons à résoudre et donc c'est
créer dans l'esprit
général un débat et qui va qui va
peut-être suscité des protestations des
inhibitions
pour ceux qui auraient envie d'investir
et donc nous avons pensé que c'était pas
à la hauteur nous avons dit qu' il
fallait pas baisser les impôts et que
s'il devait y avoir par exemple si on
veut rien dustrit alizés si on veut
relocaliser les activités
peut-être qu'il ya des impôts des
cotisations sociales et qui sont des
facteurs de de délocalisation ou de
désindustrialisation est ce qu'on n'a
pas financer les 35 heures à l'hôpital
avec des médicaments produits plutôt en
chine et en inde le genre de question
qu'il faudra se poser un jour
donc s'il doit y avoir des impôts des
cotisations sociales qui sont réduits ça
suppose qu'on augmente d'autres impôts
pour maintenir le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires ça c'est un
principe que nous avons posées sur les
règles européennes proprement dite les
échos que nous avons eus de nos d'autres
partenaires européens si vous voulez
c'est que nous sommes quand même dans
une situation singulière et je pense
qu'il faut que nous définissions nous
mêmes nos propres règles
on va pas demander il ya une règle qui
dit que quand vous n'êtes quand votre
dette est supérieure à 60%
vous avez 20 ans pour la ramener à 60 %
ceci n'est pas imaginable donc le
critère de la dette va devoir être revu
incontestablement est le critère de
critères du niveau de déficit lui aussi
mais il faut quand même qu'on pose un
principe c'est l'équilibré des finances
publiques
on admet bien sûr qu'on fasse du déficit
dans une période de crise parce que il
faut que les stabilisateurs économiques
soient soient déclenchées il faut
également que les amortisseurs sociaux
soient à la hauteur des attentes de ceux
qui souffrent et qui sont en difficulté
mais ceux ci c'est pour une période de
crise et nous disons qu'il n'est pas
question de resserrer les robinets tant
qu'on n'est pas sortis de la crise tant
qu'on n'a pas retrouvé le niveau
d'emploi et d'activité de la fin de
l'année 2019 pas d'austérité c'est bien
ce que nous avons dit
mais au delà il faut 2 oignons des
règles et des principes alors les
collectivités locales elles sont tenues
à une présentation des comptes qui les
met à l'abri de la dérive puisque et
qu'on doive s'est équilibré et que le
régulateur au fond c'est l'organisme
auprès duquel les collectivités
sollicite des emprunts il faut que la
tête des collectivités locales soit
soutenable
le problème qu'on peut avoir c'est que
les soeurs réforme fiscale qu'on ait
fait depuis 40 ans at et la suppression
des impôts locaux il ya qu'on a
décentralisé
alors que la martingale de rappel et l
impôt local mais d'assez populaire pour
les gouvernements de gauche comme de
droite de supprimer des impôts locaux
parce que ce sont pratiquement les seuls
impôts que les citoyens ont le sentiment
de payer
peut-être que rare voir ce préfet skip
là mais c'est pas simple d'établir la
peau quand vous avez autant de
collectivités locales
on se rencontre dans l'intercommunalité
c'est à dire que vous avez des matrices
on avait des matrices pour la taxe
d'habitation pour taxe foncière qui
était pas tout à fait les mêmes
alors même que ces collectivités faisait
partie de la même intercommunalité qui
lever l'impôt
le taux était le même pour tout le monde
mais les bases n'étaient pas les mêmes
donc on a peut-être un vrai sujet
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général
on a beaucoup de collectivités locales
et dans cette maison j'ai conscience que
c'est pas un sujet facile à traiter mais
si l'avenir c'est la décentralisation
encore faut-il que chaque commune ait
les moyens d'assumer les responsabilités
nouvelles
est ce que vous croyez que toutes les
communes françaises ont les moyens de le
faire et êtes vous sûr que
l'intercommunalité est toujours au
meilleur niveau 2
des règles démocratiques est ce que dans
certains cas on n'a pas l'impression que
c'est l'administration qui a pris le
pouvoir
et est ce que c est ce que c'est un
facteur est ce que c'est un facteur de
maîtrise de la dépense publique
je me prononce pas mais il va falloir
quand même qu'on se pose la question
j'entends ici ou là secret des communes
nouvelles est ce que ce n'est pas une
voie dans laquelle il faut s'engager
d'autres pays s'y sont engagés ça n'est
pas simple de poser ce genre de
questions dans une danse est maison et
j'ai vécu ce dilemme
j'ai essayé de deux syllabes j'étais
mère et j'ai essayé de fusionner quatre
communes aux 89
c'était la campagne la plus la plus dure
que j'ai jamais eu à mener bon mais cela
étant sur le fond si on veut que les
territoires se développe il faut qu' il
puisse avoir des projets de
développement il faut qu'il puisse
attirer des collaborateurs de talent
pour les aider à concrétiser ses projets
la relation entre l'état les
collectivités et une relation compliquée
parce que du fait de la suppression des
impôts locaux les collectivités défendre
très largement des compensations versées
par l'état et l'état peut être
prescripteur de dépenses mais quand on
dit l'état c'est aussi le parlement
parce que il peut arriver que vous voyez
des lois pour suggérer qu'en matière
écologique faudra créer un responsable
de ceci et de cela nous sommes quelques
fautes pris dans nos propres
contradictions
alors je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet
collectivités locales les règles
comptables et les règles de présentation
financière à mon avis aux tirs et pro
châble et le régulateur alors city nous
suggérons l'extension des contrats de
cahors c'est qu'apparemment pour les 300
et quelques contrats qui ont été
établies ça plutôt fonctionné de manière
positive et constructive
les acteurs en sont satisfaits donc
pourquoi ne pas élargir cette démarche
pourquoi ne pas l'élargir avec sans
doute la vigilance et la prudence
requise
mais enfin c'est une façon aussi de
maîtriser la dépense publique et
inversement
donc on peut pas dire qu'il ya l'état
qui d'un côté parce que l'état l'état
certainement fait des efforts mais je
pense que l'état ait été trop
centralisée et qu'il y a probablement
une sur administration des circulaires
pour recevoir les maires dans tous les
sens et en délire et peut-être que oui
mais alors nous avons le principe de
précaution nous avons la jurisprudence
du sang contaminé et face à des
situations dramatiques
vous conviendrez que des ventes du
gouvernement et de l'administration
prescriptive et responsables peuvent
avoir le souci d'éviter de se retrouver
le lendemain devant une juridiction est
mis en cause par les citoyens et ceci
est la conséquence des législations que
nous avons voté au fil des années les
uns et les autres
donc je n'hésite pas à parler d'une
véritable révolution culturelle la
gouvernance budgétaire est une chose
mais elle met en cause la gouvernance
publique en général ceci est intimement
liée à la quand on parle de gouvernance
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
possible quand même de revoir la façon
dont on travaille au parlement en
modifiant le temps que l'on consacre au
projet de loi moi le souvenir que j'en
ai si vous voulez c'est qu'on passé un
temps fou que ça ne fait pas forcément
avancer le la cause
dans certains pays on vote le budget en
quelques jours
il ya un seul ministre qui présente le
budget alors chez nous c'est l'occasion
de débats et nous avons nos habitudes et
nos procédures et chacun prépare son
rapport et est ce que est ce qu'il faut
pas qu'on s'interroge aussi sur le
conduirait la gouvernance du parlement
et quand quand un gouvernement
quand quentin par le vent s'installe au
lendemain d'une élection
comment est-ce qu'on s'y prépare comment
est-ce qu'on définit les nouvelles
méthodes pour tenter d'être plus
efficaces et d'éviter de tomber dans les
contradictions qui quelquefois nous
amène à dire qu'il faut absolument
réduire la dépense publique mais d'être
incapable de le faire en pratique
c'est ça que nous avons voulu essayer
dire dans ce rapport et ne sais pas si
nous y sommes arrivés mais nous avons
voulu essayer de le faire plus court que
les autres rapports peut-être un peu
plus pédagogique pour qu'il soit
accessible par nos concitoyens qui
souhaiteraient y jeter un oeil
et puis qu'il y ait un débat je pense
que le débat de la dette va venir devant
l'opinion publique dans lé dans les mois
qui viennent il s'agit d'essayer d'être
dans un principe de réalité
on m'avait demandé aussi si on avait des
idées sur les dépenses qu'il faudrait
réduire
nous nous disons qu'il faut que vous que
nous prenions le temps de regarder où
sont les dépenses et qu'est ce qu'on
constate on constate que c'est surtout
sur les transferts sociaux que la france
est engagée et retraite
l'assurance chômage est un vrai sujet
est ce qu'il faudrait pas que le
périmètre du plfss soit étendue à
l'unedic est au chômage
alors vous me direz mais les partenaires
sociaux vont dire que c'est leur
responsabilité sauf que dès qu'il ya eu
du déficit à l'unedic
c'est l'état qui s'est portée caution
et donc quand l'état est caution et bien
lorsqu'il veut faire quand un goût d'un
faire aboutir telle ou telle prise en
charge
il n'y a pas trop de mal à convaincre
les partenaires sociaux hélas les
responsabilités ce mélange entre l'état
et les partenaires sociaux donc là aussi
il faut que les règles de gouvernance
puisse être redéfinie sans ambiguïté
serait pas extravagant quand même que on
puisse faire apparaître ce tableau
global des dépenses publiques et des
recettes publiques et là vous verrez où
sont les masses est ce qui distingue la
france par rapport à la plupart des pays
ocde
ces transferts sociaux nous sommes allés
très loin et quand il faut amorcer une
remise en cause ça n'est pas simple mais
bon mon sentiment personnel c'est que
des raids sont un vrai sujet écrit il va
bien falloir que la prochaine que le
prochain quinquennat s'en préoccupe
et pas seulement les retraites et pas
seulement les retraites parce que
derrière tout ça c'est la crédibilité
d'un pays qui est en cause croyez vous
que la france peut faire prévaloir
systématiquement son plein
vu par ses partenaires européens dès
lors que sa situation financière est
préoccupante
on en voit tous les ans à l'application
des pactes de stabilité et de croissance
on en voit tous les ans un programme de
stabilité à bruxelles qu'on n'a jamais
respecté et dont vu par nos partenaires
européens nous passons pour des
gestionnaires singulier et comme disait
comme comme comme disait comme disait
jean claude juncker qui était ça nous a
été rappelé qu'il était président de
l'eurogroupe et ben oui ça c'est la
france
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on courait
vise notre notre position
donc je je je vous demande beaucoup de
bienveillance à notre égard c'est qu'on
n'a pas voulu fixer des des voies
empruntées systématiquement disant faut
réformer les retraites ou pour réformer
l'assurance journal parce que ce serait
se substituer au politique et ça n'était
pas monsieur le président dans notre
mission est peut-être que ça n'aurait
pas facilité l'intégrité notre groupe
jusqu'au moment de l'adoption du rapport
parce que tout rapport d'un groupe aussi
composite appel que chacun prenne sa
part de concessions sur sur les impôts
de production par exemple moi je pense
qu'il ya une vraie urgence c'est de
revoir toutes les formes d'impôt de
production comment voulez-vous
réindustrialiser un pays est recréé
l'emploi si vous financer votre
protection sociale par des cotisations
assises sur les salaires est ce que ça
n'est pas un impôt de production
j'observe que dans les pays du nord de
l'europe
on a supprimé ce type de financement de
la protection sociale au profit d'autres
impôts alors les autres impôts je me
prononcerai pas ça c'est le débat
politique et je ne veux pas me
substituer
au parlement parce que c'est le vrai
débat qui vaut avoir trop souvent nous
avons des tabous il ya des questions
qu'on ne veut pas évoquer parce que
c'est presque sacrilège parce que ça
remet en cause des données historiques
auxquels on ne veut pas toucher mais la
mondialisation est passée par là et la
mondialisation a changé la donne alors
bien sûr il nous permet d'acheter des
produits pas chers et là on va penser
que c'est une façon de maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat mais on se rend pas
compte à quel point ces corrosif en
termes d'emplois et de tissu économique
donc nous avons de vrais enjeux à
relever
faut-il revoir la lolf pour nous
suggérons de un certain nombre de
modifications organique qui vont dans le
sens d'ailleurs de ce que le président
et le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale et même la commission des
affaires sociales ont proposé nous
mettons en débat c'est ces propositions
nous ne sommes pas allés jusqu'à la
réforme constitutionnelle
saluant les collectivités locales ne
sommes pas revenus non plus sur le
principe de libre administration des
collectivités locales et nous insistons
sur la pluriannualité pas seulement pour
présenter les doigts de finances mais si
vous demandez à un directeur
d'administration de faire des réformes
et de supprimer quelques postes si
chaque année vous dites voilà l'année
prochaine nous en supprimer 3 lui il a
besoin de savoir ce qui se passe en cinq
ans parce que là il fait une vraie
réforme sur cinq ans mais si vous lui
dites année parade et ben voilà sans lui
dire ce qui se passe après
vous ne permettez pas d'engager une
réforme structurelle et de modifier la
gouvernance
donc pour nous le pluri annualité est
très importante
alors sur les collectivités locales
s'agissant des investissements
il ya des années on va investir
massivement
nous pensons que dans certains cas il
serait bon de laisser les collectivités
à voir faire des provisions pour éviter
quand l'investissement viendra d'avoir à
emprunter l'intégralité des besoins
c'est dire que si on programme un
investissement important de pouvoir
constituer des excédents pour les mettre
en provisions et financer plus
facilement avec un moindre recours à
l'emprunt donc voilà ce que ce que nous
nous sommes permis de suggérer mais au
total on peut dire que l'état providence
a bien fonctionné dans les circonstances
dramatiques que nous traversons mais ce
dont il s'agit c'est de l'avenir de
l'état providence est donc de mettre en
oeuvre une transformation radicale de la
gouvernance budgétaire
c'est peut-être une façon de préserver
l'avenir de l'état providence
faute de quoi vient amendement alors
monsieur le président vous suggérez
compte tenu des conditions extrêmement
favorables du marché d'emprunter plus
largement
alors l'emprunt il va être fait par
l'union européenne puisque l'union
européenne va emprunter 750 milliards et
que la france va récupérer
il ya un fonds de dotation de 200 4 390
milliards je prends duquel 40 milliards
seront extraits pour la france ces 40
milliards là ils ont vocation à financer
la transition écologique
nous pouvons emprunter plus monsieur le
président mais demandez-vous alors à
quel niveau vous allez stabiliser la
dette française et comment votre
attitude va être apprécié par vos
partenaires européens qui n'ont pas pris
tout à fait les mêmes orientations
donc il ya un vrai sujet dans tout cela
le le le cavalier seul français à mon
avis peut avoir des inconvénients car il
pourrait déstabiliser le fonctionnement
de la zone euro et donc nous devons
essayer de dons essayer de nous trouver
en phase et si possible en convergence
60 points d'écart entre la france et
l'allemagne c'est quand même vrai sujet
un vrai sujet
donc soyons aussi attentif je comprends
bien votre argument on peut dire ben
voilà mais je ne suis pas sûre par
ailleurs il suffit pas de dire qu'on va
mettre 10 milliards de plus sur la table
pour qu'il y ait un programme efficace
qui s'engagent immédiatement
attention il faut que le tissu soit prêt
à accueillir ces fonds supplémentaires
pour que ça fonctionne et donc tout ceci
doit être fait avec avec vigilance et
sensibilité
à quelles questions l'egypte a répondu
you nationaux plein l'allongement de la
dette alors l'allongement la france au
sein de la zone euro est le pays qui a
le plus allongée on est en moyenne à 8,2
années on était autour de cinq années il
ya dix ans la grande bretagne étaient 18
mai la grande bretagne à des fonds
d'investissement pour les retraites ce
qui n'est pas le modèle que nous avons
choisie en europe nous sommes les plus
avancées alors est-ce qu'on pourrait
est-ce qu'on pourrait emprunter plus à
15 ans et au delà faut faire très
attention parce qu'on dit moment là le
marché est très demandeur mais tous ceux
qui viennent souscrire les titres le
trésor a lancé les ouates et et on a dix
fois plus de demandes mais tous ceux qui
sont en demande vont immédiatement porté
les titres qu'ils ont pu obtenir à la
banque centrale est à mon avis au
passage ils doivent s'y trouvait un
petit revenu quand même donc méfions
nous de ceux de cette référence au
marché dans un tel contexte
car s'il n'y avait pas la banque
centrale pour acheter les titres
instantanément tu pas sûr que le marché
serait aussi aussi de vendeurs de
septième
[Musique]